Hello,
this video is to talk about the advantages of living
in the countryside
1 everywhere in Europe.
Uh,
there you go,
in all things,
I would like to remind you
that there are not only disadvantages,
because a few days ago,
I made 1 video to say the.
I didn't quote everything,
uh.
People,
that's it,
it created 1 bit of
uh.
Challenges and everything.
But as they say,
each
tells his experience.
Here it is.
So we're going to talk about the benefits.
The first thing I think is great,
uh.
In the countryside,
it is
.
Here,
already,
you breathe pure air,
there are less than
uh,
noises,
here is
less noise pollution,
so you live in harmony with nature.
Here,
there are so many corners to discover
1 everywhere in the countryside,
beautiful villages and everything.
And that's,
that's actually the benefits.
We also have solidarity,
the fact that everyone knows each other,
when you live in 1 village,
we all know each other in fact.
And when you have 1 problem,
it's easy to get help.
It's not like in the big cities where
you live 10 years in 1 building,
that you don't even know your loved ones,
no,
your neighbors.
I mean,
it's not that here,
we all know each other.
There,
where you're going to buy,
there,
there are people who notice you.
Ah but he.
There is such Black next door,
and such,
you see,
There,
if you need help,
you'll get it.
There you go.
And the next thing I'm going to say is
solidarity.
People are supportive,
maybe.
It's because there aren't many of us,
the majority in the municipalities are not many,
and all around 100,000 or 300,000
or even 150,000 people including
there is solidarity,
that's it.
And there's this,
uh,
what am I going to say here,
there are organic products.
Here,
when I say organic,
it is,
but it is really organic actually,
uh,
in the small markets in the communes,
often,
the are villagers,
people who cultivate these
things at home,
that is tomatoes,
consoles are organic.
It's not the stuff you find in big
supermarkets,
large groups
who import stuff with chemicals
1 bit everywhere, no,
you eat more organic
for example.
Uh, no,
we're going to buy the chicken next door,
and they are farm chickens
that we actually raise outdoors.
So it's organic stuff,
no flare and all.
The people are nice.
Yeah,
I forgot that too.
People are nice,
here you go.
And they don't hesitate to help you,
actually,
I.
I think it's normal,
I think it's pretty good and everything.
There is also the administrative component,
I mean,
uh,
documents,
when you need a document,
it's very,
very easy to get it when.
You're in the country,
uh,
in the slightly isolated corners,
it's easy.
I give you 1 very good example
very simple,
for someone who lives in big cities,
who wants to send 1 letter of invitation to 1 relative in
in Africa,
for the person to apply for a visa,
for example. No,
you can go in the morning
at ten o'clock and ten o'clock 5,
you go out with this document.
It is easy to make the documents here,
but the same document
when you drop off for example in a big city
like Paris or
Toulouse,
and so we have to wait the 4 months,
wanted to have the same document,
i.e.
just so that the doctor,
this paper,
you wait 4 months.
But in the countryside,
it was very,
very easy.
In fact,
when you go to the town hall,
you do it at the same time,
here,
there is that,
which is,
which is good,
which is
really what.
Ah,
we have to congratulate you.
But there you go,
also in terms of renewals,
at the prefecture level,
so it's like 1 depends,
it is
when you file your renewal applications or
request for type of stay,
it is quickly treated.
It's not like in the
large cities
again,
where you have to wait 1 year or
Here it is,
2 years sometimes to have 1 type of stay,
no,
No,
10.
In the countryside,
most teachers,
including you,
from.
You depend.
Uh.
Like a girl with those documents.
And there you go,
already 2 months,
3 months,
you have 1 answer and everything.
I find it very,
very positive.
And there you go,
in a way. Well,
I can't tell everything,
I want to let people
who have experiences to tell also
the no truth in the comments.
So that's it.
If we can ask to choose
between living
in the big cities and live in the countryside,
Well,
the choice is made.
I.
I'll choose.
Uh.
The countryside.
That's it.
There is peace and quiet.
, it depends.
It is.
It's to everyone's taste.
In fact.
I like peace and quiet.
And there you go,
I find that in thes,
it is too complicated,
too many people.
No,
it's not my thing.
Come on,
thank you and
pass 1 good night.